bethany frankel is the new york times
best-selling author philanthropist and
self-made entrepreneur she does a lot of
stuff that bethenny frankel and now
she's adding a new title to her resume
listen to this beauty influencer what
her beauty reviews on both luxury and
drugstore products have
really exploded on tick tock since
spring her fan base grew by nearly half
a million followers who watch her take
on what's worth it and what's not worth
it her opinions are based strictly on
her own personal experience here's
bethany
it gives you the toastiest glow that is
so easy to attain that even an idiot
could not screw it up
because it's not too dark it's not
gloppy on the topic this is crazy it's
gigantic
how are you going to travel with this if
you don't have a private plane you have
to be a billionaire to use this product
because if you don't have a private
plane how are you traveling with this
look at the difference in my two
eyelashes that was one coat this is like
an a plus plus mascara
well most of us don't have private
planes frankel's the author of business
is personal the truth about what it
takes to be successful while staying
true to yourself bethany frankel joins
us she was here earlier with her book
and now she's back as a beauty in
tonight i love your adjectives here the
toastiest glow
tony i just think bethany likes to stir
stuff up you stirred stuff up on real
housewives yes now you're back as a
beauty influencer yes how did that
happen i mean when guys when bethany
walked in the studio she goes this is
crazy to me this is hilarious you
started this bethany well but march 31st
i think it was when i started just
doing my makeup i don't know how to do
my own makeup and i don't wear makeup
which is the irony but i was so i was so
confused with all the messaging and all
the marketing and i wanted to cut
through and i started doing this just
comparing i would have a fifty dollar
side of my face to a 500 to see if it
makes a difference is drugstore just as
good the answer is yes
well that's interesting yes and the moms
were all reaching out saying thank you
because i said if you're an expert keep
scrolling if you are a person who just
wants to get out the door in 10 minutes
and figure out how to make a difference
in your face
then maybe we'll learn something
together and so i just decluttered this
space and what are you finding i'm
finding that listen there's an
emotionality to the packaging and things
that make you feel special like any like
a handbag or anything we own so
drugstores have to be mindful of that
and that there's no one brand every
brand has one hero item and then the
rest could be garbage like you got to
kind of pick and choose do an a la carte
menu no one skincare line should you do
12 steps every single day because your
skin's different every single day you're
dehydrated your pores are clogged and
that we're being marketed to but most
importantly most things do everything a
blush can be an eye shadow an eyeshadow
can be a lip gloss if you mix it with
the right cream a blush can be an
eyeshadow yes you can mix it to get the
matte look i didn't realize that a
highlighter could be for the pop of
shimmer on your eyes so we're being
marketed the same products over and over
foundation in a darker color yeah
becomes a bronzer so you could have like
only 10 things and get you through your
face yes i'm fascinated by this because
i for me makeup is still paint by
numbers i couldn't put on a lash you
held a gun in my head so i'm fascinated
that you're doing that yeah that'd be an
interesting kind of criminal
the weapon was like put that ladder on
immediately uh so this is connecting
right people want these reviews they
like them they're clarifying you're
cutting through the clutter but it's
interesting that you've also accused
instagram and i believe tick tock also
of shadow banning and for people who
don't know what that is it means
de-emphasizing your videos because of
the content not banning you but just not
putting them in front of as many viewers
right i'm accusing some
system some some element i don't know
that it's that it's instagram or twitter
or that it's someone's um team or that
you know i know that people can push
things down in the media people can make
a change with their teams of tech you
know wizards so i don't know where it
came from but i do know that i posted i
post beauty reviews that are fair and i
posted about the kardashians about their
negative influence on society in my
opinion and i uh spoke about kim
kardashian's skin care and immediately
multiple videos of mine were getting
fewer than 10 of what they normally get
but i mean video after video so i would
normally get
30 to 50 000 views in an hour and then i
was getting 400 views or up to so you're
saying somebody was deliberately some
i don't know about somebody or some
element but it what it's a fact that it
went down so you're not saying instagram
or tick tock but i did so i have to read
this little bit here uh that instagram
told us in a statement that there are no
restrictions on your account and any
claims that we shadow ban are untrue as
a general statement and tick tock we
never heard back from them right well
tick tock the people in the united
states aren't really responding and it's
in china i know that it absolutely
happened but i have no idea
what manipulates the system okay there's
a picture that you posted on instagram
can we put up this picture of bethany
where you said this is a before and
after and i'm looking at this i go
bethany what's the before and what's the
after well i'm calling a little okay so
they're calling out on that you look
good in both of those i'm sure i think i
look good too but this is the first time
i've ever done this because i'm always
with no makeup so i just cinched my
waist a little bit made the boobs a
little bigger and if you keep doing that
over time and people start to get used
to you doing that it makes young women
uh have a false ideal young men look for
the wrong things and i think it's
damaging to young people i know it's
damaging people are are dieting
excessively they want to look like these
pictures and it's absolutely not
inspirational it's destructive for
people to filter and make themselves
look like a different version of them
but you start with a pretty good before
picture i had a picture of me the other
day i go god my dress is all bunched up
it was my tummy so i'm thinking that's a
good position right it changes the
standard i know i get trains what men
are looking at and they don't understand
what normal is anymore and as a mother
of between i know i see what's going on
and they feel insecure why don't they
look like that why isn't my waist this
small why aren't my boobs this big why
don't i have these barbie-like
proportions and it's irresponsible and
i'm not here for it well real housewives
is bringing on an influence influencer
next to be the next house why would you
ever consider going back
i can't see any reason to go back i
really can't i'm actually walking on the
beach with andy tomorrow and we love
wanting to talk so so
we're talking about what we'll do next
together
walk on the beach with bethany and andy
i want to go on thank you thank you
hey andy